[Music]
hey guys how are you good you're good
yeah I like your voice alright so I just
picked up Isaac we just had lunch and
now we're gonna be heading over to Vince
our friend Vince's house and Vince
I don't really know his like resume per
se like exactly what he's achieved I
just know that he is a really really
really cold breakdancer and he's been
breakdancing for a minute and he now
teaches kids how to breakdance since
we're gonna be going over it was that
you practicing break done doing it what
do you know oh that's pretty good oh
that's pretty good baby we gotta show
Vince when we get there
yeah are you excited to go breakdance
event yeah I know me too because I know
little I actually wanted to learn how to
break down to have these cousins that
they were so into break dancing like
crazy but yeah so I'm really looking
forward to learning some more all right
now my lips are on fire because this
morning I went shopping to Sephora with
Gio and then on the way out you know how
I Sephora they have all these like mini
things and then they kinda entice you to
buy a whole bunch of stuff and so Gio
and I couldn't resist and we like
ransack the whole thing we were looking
at everything that they had and one of
the products that I bought was this Too
Faced lip injection extreme thing so it
was like plump up your lips it's a lip
gloss and I just put it on right before
you coming and I feel my lips are all
like on fire did it look one beer I
don't know these these things are always
fun to test out you know anyway so we're
gonna head over to Vince's and go see
what he has in store for us he's superb
he's a vegan so cute hi Joey pie you're
so cute
are you practicing being a big brother
what happened
scratched you you touched his butt no no
are you wiping it on the couch go wash
your hand
here your run is funny
so mom yes it's good lighting
[Music]
so yeah I'm actually pretty excited to
go breakdance because I tried to do it I
tried to breakdance before but it wasn't
successful really what you're doing the
two things I meant
yeah I never done it correctly I feel
like how did you know what breakdancing
I don't know I didn't heard about it
like I remember seeing someone do it
like in the movie and then I did it and
then it people were saying like those
breakdance so now I get I learn the
proper way alright guys yeah there's Ben
what's up dude I am so excited to learn
breakdancing Romeo I like how you have
your entire like breakdancing floor or
what is that called dancing floor or
yeah that's what the DA Stancil perfect
fitting come over that's so funny you
used to just be that commandant and then
I bought that it's like martial art man
oh is it softer oh that's cool a little
bit softer it's still firm dude I don't
hurt yourself I know that's exactly my
biggest fear right now is like slipping
and then like busting my lip or
something by accident cuz I'm trying to
get too fancy
ya know for sure but you know what I was
telling them earlier I'm like I know
you're legit in the breakdancing world
but I don't really know much about your
whole rap sheet like your resume of
breakdancing I don't know well I guess I
grew up in
Sacramento I grew up doing this dancing
hopefully learning like it's like like
most ancestry dancers like a self-taught
there too and when I was from like 16 to
like 20-something we're used to compete
a lot for a playing it with every
weekend we'd be chosen for a competition
whether
sometimes you know at a state at a
country well greatly but then when I was
in college I actually got into teaching
not as a way to pay for my rent keep in
my car yeah and then actually when I
graduated from college I was like I
really like teaching so I actually
pursued I ran a program in Sacramento
for ten years teaching in elementary and
middle school now I'm here in Los
Angeles doing the same thing on the
elementary schools teaching breaking two
kids and neighborhoods where otherwise
they wouldn't get it like art experience
oh that's so cool in the past like ten
years breaking is changed a lot like
when I was younger it was very like
underground very like you have your own
crew and you dance by yourself and you
go enter a competition and it's all very
small yeah but now because of social
media people get sponsors it's growing
like there's even like word that it
might be a little big sin the promise of
crazy angel eyes done from very
undergoing expanding
exciting times right now we're ready
baby yeah
you look cool that leather jacket Modi
you're gonna dancing that you know he
was ready for it
today we're basically learning how to
freestyle first and then we will add to
it to start off at once you guys just
walk in like a little circle right in
front of you you guys go ahead to
squawking I'll start some funny like
you're warming up to go dance right and
then we have to add one thing
Tiffany already got we got to add some
style to it right so you guys walk walk
with Styles nod your head lean side to
side like you mean business alright and
then you start dancing I mean that style
kind of go into your dancing too so add
it to it in there
oh my oh oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there you go trying to run into you got
it
[Music]
there's a workout okay rusty for
forwards very like a car do a lot of
cardio
[Music]
three in there like slowly hey that's it
you got it we want to get to a point
where we can be completely on our
shoulder without having to use
everything about so once you get there
it's really easy it's intimidating you
could do it I'm gonna grab your foot to
help balance and then try to lift that
leg up balance it it takes time it takes
time take your time you guys might have
you probably you might actually know
this you might know this - it's called a
coffee grinder yeah I've seen that
before
pretty common move and we're going to
use that as kind of like a transition to
get into our freeze Isaac scooper just a
little bit swing there you go and jump
more time swing and jump and now all
together Eddie swing nice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we just finished our lesson
thank you so much event no problem it
was so freaking fun guys it an amazing
job thank you and what's your channel so
you can check out our the video that we
just shot my channel is insanity V and
dance tutorials from beginner all the
way to beds nice so I think eyes gonna
also learn how we just did hit up his
channel go check out those videos and
then you can be a b-boy or b-girl
yourself how'd you feel baby so I know
his voice is like way more calmer in his
entire right he's like a new person
no it was so much fun I honestly felt my
body hit the limits of what it can do
because there are so many times where I
had to do like a certain pose I'm like
my hip my hip is cramping it can take
like say I feel old I got it I got
exercise mat you do this like that when
I dance too I feel the same way I feel
like really like if I'm like stressed
out about something it's like meditation
yeah well sorry but this whole time my
camera could not focus on you so I'm
like I'm like sorry guys I'm you're like
looking at dirtiness and clearer than
blurry this cameras doesn't want to
focus anyway yeah thank you so much for
having us of course I am definitely
gonna come back and bug you to use your
dance floor and have you teach us some
work then we'll go hit up we'll go ahead
a part
yeah go competition you ready go compete
yeah cutie pie I love enthusiasm
alright so now we're gonna go eat Casey
is in a meeting or else he would be here
but he had this last minute film meeting
so he wasn't able to join us in this
class but yeah we're gonna go eat and
I'm hopefully by then you'll see Casey
it alright so now we're eating at this
place called views at bueng solid look
at this I have been craving via there
for a while so I'm just so happy we came
to eat here but it's like the opposite
so we were doing a lot of exercise so if
I break dancing and then now we're gonna
need a whole bunch of greasy foods which
is perfect baby smelling it would you
get Ksenia Familia so good
[Music]
all right we're home now Casey is
cooking he's right over there I know
we're be boys now be Boyd be girl I
don't know what you learned you duh that
like why did I dress this way if I
wasn't gonna be doing anything they're
gonna he's ready to show you show daddy
what you learned today
what was I called again I already forgot
top something show the coffee grinder
Hey
and I've shown the the poses the fries
cousin nice maybe if you practice a
little bit more
[Music]
[Music]